hey guys all we going I'm hanging out
with road today I love stealing your
setup it just looks so good oh thank you
okay we lucked out because it is usually
raining every day in California really
and look it's beautiful nice out we can
go back with ye and see why we just
filmed a taste test challenge on Rose
Channel so good love it
Oh pineapple tree and we had to
determine do you think you boys mind
Apple or not okay we are going to be
making something super super exciting
Jenna and I did a video ever made tiny
little peep bones and these are tiny
little chicken nugget oh my god okay not
me although confuse with nerdy nummies
this is yummy nah I mean it's different
it's a different brand okay
minis nugget maker super time you taste
like real chicken nuts it tastes like
real nugget I don't think they can call
it chicken because I think it's not
chicken
Oh tender and perfect for dipping whoo
after we make those we're going to make
some little drinks to go with it oh my
god we're concerned it's like a whole
soda station yeah we're just uh put that
aside while we work on our chicken
nuggets what are your honor
yeah I always destroy have a change in
your busy focusing on we've opened two
things in my video so I'm gonna do it in
here really okay look open these little
oh oh you can rip it I think your
direction direction inside we don't need
any of it perfect okay oh okay see now
how is this good at the second target
Oh God and he's exercising to use the
scissors and microwave should be
performed by an adult
we've got you adults today too I'm the
mole good thing we have an assault handy
too
opens the Nugget packet makes nine feet
of nugget powder four scoops of water
the weeds of water for the summer fight
yeah but this smells like allspice this
is meat chicken meat right this one to
you okay you wanna do a couple yeah okay
so spawn this would be G just like to be
weird precise huh that memory a next
nine nine baby alright that's a limit
along soon
well we all have one measurement yes
cookie made this maker Langley here for
the children what are the ages on the
six plus six plus you bought more
student loves confronted for yes making
dealt with this is our chicken nugget
have you ever seen anything like no it
goes looks like dough it doesn't really
look like a nugget and then separate the
mixture into four equal parts and roll
it into balls here you go here's your
explain yep like maybe a vert ramen
noodle is it something we're eating just
keep that in mind
there's an Mel's like a burnt ramen
noodle I don't know you guys have had
ramen noodles I love them no sound like
a burnt one oh we're a business okay so
what to say after number alright
adios skip a bread crumb take a packet
stay tuned this is what you do really
when you prepare food you know you
prepare your meat and then you promise
know if you're going to do like a baked
a baked chicken I don't really think
about the delicious well where do you
put that when you're done up I don't
know okay why oh right when you're done
step 5 mmm solution
now this is disgusting it's really
different right
yeah different kind this makes 10
Nuggets so you got to keep doing this
we're only going to make four how our
chicks looking oh we need a microwave I
got one for what are you doing like that
oh you know am I on something you're
you're on the table okay great we only
need it for 15 seconds look I gotta get
an extension cord on the right map it
only dates for 15 seconds okay okay so
this end goes here mix together two
scoops of the ketchup packet it's not
red is it gonna turn red I have no idea
look at it it's white oh right it's
turning red now whoa
okay so we're going to mix this up how
this looks it's no just like the chicken
only a thread
all right well stick them in there Oh
yep start chicken math there we go let's
see this is a high-powered microwaves
cleaner so hopefully well but smells
like chicken and now we gotta wait 30
seconds
okay let's take it out see oh my gosh I
think it smells like an erasers they all
like me stuck an eraser in the my throat
a room see I can get some type of dough
or flower with some technique you
the chicken is a lie it doesn't kind of
smell like an eraser oh god I look up I
like their smell is I think this is my
to keep yeah we brought in purpose here
I'll take it out it's okay one of the
pieces of advice that they give to a
dome is avoid ingredients coming into
contact with your eyes oh that step
eight right here is this the Nugget in
the ketchup sauce and enjoy
step 8 how do most women let's take this
20 is the closest to me oh it's warm it
is more warm give you a little dip
definitely not ketchup I hope I enjoy it
oh you need the whole thing you just
take a bite
it's a by a high ceiling piece of bread
yeah it's like a little roll thanks
ready
Susana Oh yep contains wheat and milk
and soy no taste kind of like the bread
risk a superb look like one step it's
definitely lighter than your deployed
kick it in a very dark red I'm sorry
justice a lot of pink in it
you dare me to be in specific I'll get
my finger answer okay nice scoop we
taste it please God
look it's pretty jealous it's really
spicy it is really exciting isn't it
seven days like ketchup
it's like a um I think when I said
before a bully on cue a little spice
cute it's like a liquid version of that
I don't have a little piece and we got
to make the drink eight yeah I think
this will be a little bit better
[Music]
this is science looks like a science kit
MLB pack not our machine pal
this looks to be a little more
complicated than our previous yeah maybe
I shouldn't open up a cola shop okay
oh shoot when we miss one filtrate what
is fixed to the first still ones a lot I
didn't love there were two adult that we
missed f1 I thought this was step one me
too yeah well being a picture big
picture look like
step one it was step this big picture
was step two it was how about me no that
looks like step one we both didn't see
it all right it's okay we action matter
okay all right that's pretty I mean I
think I'll fulfill one oh my goodness
okay we got to figure out which one of
those two wits we're not going to mess
this up I mean we're gonna do this right
it seems to be a little bit doing yeah
that's cool too dissolved I wonder if it
just takes a while for it to dissolve
yeah it's a little chunky blender you
know there's a new one look at that
disgusting which it is here you want to
use a bumper car mounted whoo this is
like science class you have squeeze all
of the air and they call it a teardrop
er but you could also it's a mini
pipette yeah Sian I wouldn't wait I
remember there being a brown one oh my
god I probably off I don't think it
really matter
everything is good I met for a missing
one but that's alright it was hiding you
were right you did see one we need three
scoops of vanilla base hold up
because mmm smell the playset pink of
water to the fill line there should be a
line there somewhere else
one oh I mix it up just singing mimics
Nick make sure you mix well so
everything's looking good we need three
scoops of Matt and Karen and that'll be
here that's the end of step 5 right half
way full with vanilla oh here we go oh
that's nice
it doesn't think how many drops but you
can pick whatever little flavoring
really boiled it I'll do a blue dome us
though I didn't see that doesn't say I
put 5 drops you place your drink
underneath turn the knob and add the
powder add a curly straw and enjoy the
clapping ahh to not be mixing yeah
they're just they're like new balls that
look cool no I don't think so
he has a fit and then we add a straw and
enjoy this could surprise us Justine
this could be just amazing you might not
make it
our next video but all right
wouldn't be quiet
every year my nose liquid airborne it
definitely does have a very alcohol
today like those earphones yeah I'm so
weird but why is it mmm oh I got all the
jelly yeah oh oh oh
driver oh so I would suggest drinking
these through the strong because when
you drink through the story you don't
get any of that jelly okay this is a lot
of jelly I'd rather eat kind of those
chicken nuggets and drink one of these
now these are not what the greatest hmm
oh it's business look at that really
you're getting a science reaction here I
like that oh no what do you think of
this even a lot of steps to make soda
when I felt like using a mini soda
stream would have been easier we just
did a lot of work for nothing
yeah I don't know kid just probably
isn't one you want to do it just never
gotten to a liquid state there's jelly
there's solid material at the bottom it
was fun to do the science experiment
part like I like doing all this that was
fun look at everything maybe we can just
do a little shot of them bubble gum
doesn't really taste like bubble gum
perfectly that I feel like it tastes
like when you want to numb your throat
like if you have a sore throat so that's
it ah thank you guys for watching I hope
you enjoyed this a little more than me
quit painting it I didn't found making
it yeah we do I am done making in I
actually enjoyed the chicken nugget in
more than a soda yeah we finally it
wasn't bad if it wasn't good but it
wasn't it was pretty bad
yeah I mean weirder than I was expecting
I was expecting to likes a little soda
during floor yeah I ended up liking a
little like wheat Nuggets I will say it
was super fun to make so thank you so
much for making evil creations with me
I'm so excited you have so many more to
go I did I found this little chart and
just being you very many little pieces
yeah and now we've done a little nugget
yeah I feel like you might need to do a
sweet treat neck maybe you'll see
look-alikes and we can do those for
another day well thank you guys so much
for watching make sure you check out
Rose Channel I'll put all the links in
the description and be sure to watch the
fun that taste test challenge that we
did and
my novel candies that was really good I
will be good later by this thing this
thing this thing is just ice burning you
cannot figure it out you know
[Music]